PROFESSOR: Scattering, so
where did we get to last time?
We did the following things.
This is a recap.
We wrote the solution,
a scattering solution,
or I'll use r.
And this solution
had a wave that
represented the incoming
wave, and it had what
we call the scattered wave.
So there were two
pieces to the solution.
We understood that setting
up a scattering problem
with a central potential.
We had a wave that came in.
And then we had
the spherical wave,
and that was an
outgoing spherical wave.
I've added the subscript
k to represent the wave
number or the k of the wave.
This is an energy island
state we're calculating.
And therefore, the energy is h
bar squared k squared over 2m.
And we're writing the
solution with that energy.
That's an energy island state.
And this solution is, as
written, not an exact solution
of the Schrodinger equation.
But it's approximately exact
for r much greater than a,
where a is the range
of your potential.
So this is only
valid in those cases.
It's not valid near
the scattering.
For r near zero,
that's not true.
And it's not an exact solution.
This would have been
an exact solution
of the wave of the time
independent Schrodinger
equation.
And this without the f would
have been an exact solution.
But with the f is an
approximate solution.
But that's a solution
that represents
the physics of scattering.
Then we also showed that the
differential cross section
was in fact given
by this function f.
So this function f is
really what we're after.
And if we know f, we know the
differential cross section,
which is something we
measure experimentally.
We're scattering particles,
and we detect them.
And the differential
cross section
tells us about our ability
and the number of particles
that each detector picks up.
Then we've restricted
ourselves to the case
of central potentials.
And for those
central potentials,
v of r with some function
of just the scalar distance.
In such cases, the
cross section would not
have a fine dependence.
You can imagine
here is the object.
It's vertically symmetric,
and you're shooting waves.
And therefore, the cross
section and the amplitude
will be independent
of the angle phi.
There's already a direction
picked up by the incoming wave.
But otherwise, it's just that.
So we wrote solutions
in those cases.
If we are going to
solve, as we will
today, some of
these problems, you
need to write
complete solutions.
And spherical solutions
are of this form.
Although, the
relevant ones that we
will be using will have no m.
We'll be focusing in solutions
that have m equals zero.
For us, m will be equal to zero.
But these are the
general solutions.
So maybe I might as
well constrain ourselves
to our case, already
central potential.
So we will have
solutions of this kind.
And these are solutions
of the radial equation.
And we reviewed those and
mentioned that psi of r
would be given by
Al Jl of kr plus Bl
Nl of kr times Yl0 of omega.
This will be our solutions.
These are the spherical
Bessel functions.
And those were
solutions that are valid
as long as you are away
from the scattering center.
So this is valid for
r greater than a.
Indeed, you know that this
could not be valid all the way
to the center of the part
of where this scattering is
happening, because ada is
divergent as r goes to zero.
So this is not the solution.
This is just the solution
for r greater than a,
where a is the range
of the potential.
Imagine a potential that
totally becomes zero
after some distance a, then
that is your solution for r
greater than a.
That is the most
general solution
given the spherical
symmetry of this equation.
Then the last thing
we discussed was
that one part of our
solution, e to the ikz,
could be written in that
way, because it's a solution.
So it must admit an
expansion of this form.
So it is like this.
You have a sum over all else
with some funny coefficients,
including i to the
l, Yl0 of omega.
I might as well no put
theta, because there's
no phi dependence in Yl0.
Jl of kr.
So this is a pretty
remarkable expression,
we commented last time,
that represents your plane
waves as spherical waves.
Last, but not least,
we have an expansion
that is useful for
a large argument
of the spherical
Bessel functions.
They both fall off, like
one over the argument,
with sines and cosines.
And you see a constant shift
there in this sines and cosines
of l pi over two.
And this is for x much greater
than one, not exact either,
but approximate.
OK, so these are some of
our ingredients are ready.
That's how far we got.
And now, we're going to
try to get more information
and learn how to solve for fk.
We need to calculate fk.
If you have a given problem,
you want the current section,
you need fk.
Now the thing we're going
to do is a little intricate,
a lot of funny
formulas, so let's try
to keep the ideas
very clear about it.
So--